[Musica]
Che bello siamo tutti qui siamo qui ad
ascoltare dei talks ed è emozionante
perché condividiamo un momento di
comunicazione straordinaria ci
raccontiamo storie condividiamo idee e
ci emozioniamo i momenti come questo
l'azione che conta succede Tutta qui
nelle nostre teste Avete mai pensato per
esempio cosa sta succedendo adesso
mentre formule questa frase nella mia
testa le cellule del cervello i neuroni
si attivano si scambiano Segnali
elettrici l'informazione viene passata
ai centri del linguaggio poi arriva alle
mie corde vocali si trasforma in suono
che raggiunge le vostre orecchie
dalle vostre orecchie Segnali elettrici
attivano diversi gruppi di neuroni
contattano memorie suscitano idee
attivano riflessioni ed emozioni
nel tempo di una frase un concerto di
migliaia di neuroni che attivano
miliardi di Segnali elettrici un po'
come uno spettacolo pirotecnico che si
attua in un secondo ma senza spettatori
E allora contemplando questa macchina
biologica complessa che è il nostro
cervello
è normale che vengono tante domande e
personalmente quella che mi faccio è una
Come si forma il nostro cervello
e non lo chiedo in maniera superficiale
Vorrei sapere come facciamo i conti con
fatti come per esempio il fatto che è
subito dopo la nascita abbiamo già tutti
al loro posto le cellule del nostro
cervello sono decine di miliardi e non
sono tutti uguali sono di migliaia di
tipi come tasselli di diversi colori e
forme a comporre un mosaico enorme
complesso
come fa questo questo mosaico a formarsi
Come fanno i vari tasselli a sapere come
prendere il proprio posto prima che noi
nasciamo in quel piccolo embrione le
poche cellule Come fanno a sapere che
devono moltiplicarsi Come fanno a sapere
quando trasformarsi e come trasformarsi
nella giusta tessera così da formare il
mosaico
Mi fa contento vedere delle facce almeno
qui davanti
dell'interesse Siete proprio presenti
intagliati da queste domande Mi fa molto
piacere e per voi voglio dirvi voglio
dirvi che due notizie una cattiva
notizia e una buona la cattiva che in
realtà non sono qui per dare le risposte
a queste domande voglio invece parlarvi
di qualcosa di diverso e se vi siete
incuriositi Vi siete avvicinati alle
persone di cui voglio parlarvi sono
persone che si lasciano intrigare
davvero tanto da queste domande da tante
domande e che spendono la loro vita per
dare risposte sono scienziate e
scienziati sono migliaia io sono uno di
loro ognuno con le proprie domande e per
esempio le domande che ho posto Prima
sono quelle che caratterizzano
l'attività del mio gruppo di ricerca
siamo comunque accomunati
indipendentemente dal fatto che ognuno
ha le proprie domande dal fatto che
vogliamo Estendere la conoscenza oltre
ciò che è noto
è davvero difficile da immaginare come
questo si faccia pensate e che io prima
di averne esperienza diretta prima di
farlo non avevo proprio idea a scuola
non mi servito imparare nozioni e
imparare come dedurre delle leggi da
principi generali come in fisica
imparare i suoi esperimenti del passato
come in Biologia non mi ha aiutato a
capire come si porta avanti un progetto
di ricerca non era facile comprendere a
che però lo si facesse è come ogni
giorno lo supportasse davvero avanti
passo per passo
e quindi come si lavora da scienziati e
come possiamo capirlo beh
[Musica]
è tutto molto pragmatico e viene
raggiunta la soluzione a questi problemi
Grazie e momenti di intuizione
eccezionale tra adrenalina in effetti
speciali flash
è tutto finto però è chiaro Penso che
tutti ci rendiamo conto che sono delle
narrative atte a sicuramente
intrattenerci non c'è niente di male
però a volte questa distorsione può
avere effetti più profondi su come la
società rispondi a momenti seri
e per esempio pensate a quando compare
il momento in cui lo scienziato formula
un'ipotesi Come si approccia vuole fare
in tutti i modi in questi film vuole
fare in tutti i modi per dimostrare che
ha ragione vuole in qualche modo
mettersi al centro e dire Guarda era
come dicevo io ero come pensavo io ma è
tutto capovolto una vera scienziata un
vero scienziato non farebbero così
metterebbero sotto il microscopio lo
repotesi proverà cercherebbero di
provare di avere torto farebbero tutti
gli esperimenti necessari per dimostrare
che non hanno ragione è soltanto se
tutti gli esperimenti fanno la stessa
direzione allora sì che lo scienziato è
disposto ad accettare che quella era la
risposta si fa così buona scienza
Proviamo adesso per un secondo
continuare questo percorso per costruire
un ritratto dello scienziato Io
prenderei l'idea del genio solitario lo
buttare via
scienziati e scienziate sono persone
appassionate che cominciano il loro
percorso di studi un po' come tutti è
per esempio fanno l'università ottengono
una laurea ma non sono questi studi di
per sé non è questa laurea che gli dai
il diritto di Essere licenziati non non
è qui che si compie il tutto è soltanto
un inizio sono i primi passi in cui si
imparano contenuti si ottengono i mezzi
per poi e arrivare al momento in cui si
ci guarda allo specchio si dice Io sono
una scienziata Io sono uno scienziato
questo momento arriva più tardi arriva
spesso durante sempre il dottorato il
momento in cui una persona si pone di
fronte alla conoscenza globale vuole
dare un suo contributo
durante un dottorato si mettono in
discussione
le conosci la conoscenza globale si
portano esperimenti e si presentano ai
propri colleghi alla comunità
scientifica che però non è lì a dire
bravo vuole sentire che esperimenti che
hai fatto Vuole i dati alla mano capire
perché noi pensiamo che la natura sia
così diventare uno scienziato quindi non
è una collezione di titoli non è
arrivare a poter compiere la professione
semmai un percorso di crescita
intellettuale e analitica vogliamo per
esempio essere capaci di sviluppare
un'ipotesi vogliamo sviluppare il nostro
spirito critico e imparare anche
imparare senza che nessuno ci insegna
autonomamente dobbiamo essere bravi a
trovare quella crepa una delle tante
crepe nel muro che c'è tra Noto e Ignoto
E quando lo abbiamo trovata vogliamo
aprire un abbraccio
per identificare questa crepa c'è
bisogno sia di una conoscenza
approfondita che di curiosità soltanto
asiane si può dare luce quindi a una
domanda una domanda che mette un
interrogativo che ci mostra un tassello
mancante
per rifinire questa domanda dobbiamo
Innanzitutto chiederci sta esponendo una
ignoranza personale o globale o cosmica
Infatti dobbiamo documentarci per capire
se qualcuno abbia già mangiato risposta
qualcuno abbia contribuito con
esperimenti a provare a capire come
e quindi soltanto in quel momento Dopo
che siamo Documentati siamo pronti ad
aprire un abbraccio per esempio nel mio
laboratorio i membri del mio laboratorio
hanno ognuno una breccia D'Aprile Una
crepa da attaccare hanno dei progetti di
ricerca disegnano gli esperimenti li
mettono in atto e raccogliere raccolgono
i dati realizzano in questo modo svelano
un esperto della natura nuovo
ma lasciatevi dire la natura non è
chiacchierona raccogliere dati è
difficile
analizzarli ancora di più interpretarli
e poi l'apice E allora dobbiamo essere
pronti a fallimenti dobbiamo essere
pronti a sorprese a The Tour arriva
spesso il momento in cui ci rendiamo
conto che è quello che sappiamo e anche
quello che possiamo imparare in un tempo
ragionevole va al di là di delle
conoscenze che sono necessarie per
aprire questa Breccia per dare una
risposta e allora lì che la
collaborazione diventa un momento
importante per per fare scienza Gli
scienziati non sono geni solitari
lavorano in gruppo lavorano in squadre è
soltanto grazie a questo concerto di
esperienze si può arrivare a fare una
scoperta
Ma chi sono Sono donne sono uomini sono
di diverse etnie di diversi e paesi
tutti i background religiosi sono solo
noi c'è solo un unico comune
denominatore la curiosità
e Allora continuiamo ad immedesimarci
chiediamoci di cosa hanno bisogno questi
scienziati immaginatevi davanti questo
questo continuo impegno questa volontà
di scoprire qualcosa che importa per
tutti che è importante per tutti noi
all'inizio sembra una montagna
insormontabile abbiamo bisogno quindi
del supporto di mentori di persone che
ci diano consigli che sblocchino momenti
in cui siamo bloccati che sono disposti
a criticare e attaccare delle idee
illusioni superficiali per dare spazio
poi alle idee quelle forti quelle quelle
giuste
questo bisogno di supporto porta gli
scienziati vicini a noi insieme alle
altre cose che vi ho detto Per esempio
che non sono dei geni solitari che non
sono arroganti che cercano davvero di
trovare qualcosa di importante per noi
dovrebbe portarvi vicino a queste queste
figure a noi
e forse vi sorprenderà un po' Ma c'è
qualcosa che voi tutti voi potete dare
loro e che di cui loro hanno davvero
bisogno e la fiducia
e sembra facile però la fiducia costa
sempre avere fiducia vuol dire
sospendere il sospetto vuol dire
mordersi la lingua quando sei lì a dire
ma a me non convince Mi hanno detto che
forse ci stanno prendendo un po' in giro
Bisogna resistere a bufale Bisogna
resistere alla tentazione di seguire dei
complottiste Dobbiamo prenderci il tempo
di ascoltarle questi scienziati e questi
scienziati che ci dicono con spirito di
responsabilità e delle risposte alle
domande che abbiamo
avere fiducia vuol dire credere nella
curiosità
credere nella creatività per mettere che
si che si facciano dei dei progetti che
sono finalizzati non soltanto a
non soltanto delle etichette culerò il
cancro aiuterò a curare L'Alzheimer
Certo è importante però dobbiamo fare
anche ricerca che è finalizzata
semplicemente al sapere perché Sappiate
guidati dalla curiosità si possono fare
scoperte importanti i piloti della
curiosità per esempio sono fatte molte
scoperte che hanno aiutato a curare
tante malattie
infine avere fiducia vuol dire fidarsi
dei giovani
significa
permettere ai giovani diventare
scienziati di domani per mettere i
giovani diventare scienziati di domani è
una necessità oggi prima che sia troppo
tardi prima che loro entusiasmo si
affievolisca
perdendoli alla disillusione perdiamo
noi la possibilità di giovare delle loro
scoperte
rispettiamoci quindi e confidiamo in chi
scoprirà per noi e con noi un futuro
pieno di sorprese Grazie